.
>> Jesse: WE CREDIT "THE DAILY
MAIL" FOR THOSE EXCLUSIVE PHOTOS
OF THE WALL.
LET'S BRING IN LOUISIANA SENATOR
JOHN KENNEDY.
HOW HAS THE THREE AMIGO'S SUMMIT
BEEN GOING?
>> I'M PLEASED THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN WENT TO THE BORDER.
I'M PLEASED THAT HE SAYS HE WILL
DO BETTER IN TERMS OF ENFORCING
AMERICA'S IMMIGRATION LAWS.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE MAY BE
POORER UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN BUT
THEY'RE NOT STUPID.
TO BE TRUSTED, YOU HAVE TO BE
TRUSTWORTHY.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO THE BORDER,
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS NOT BEEN
TRUSTWORTHY.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE BORDER,
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS -- HE IS
ABOUT AS CREDIBLE AS JUSSIE
SMOLLETT AT ANY MOMENT COULD
ANNOUNCE THAT WILL SMITH SLAPPED
HIM, TOO.
SO, WHAT I SAY TO THE PRESIDENT
IS, IF YOU WANT TO BE TRUSTED
WITH THE BORDER, TRUST THE LAW.
INSTITUTE A REMAIN IN MEXICO
PROGRAM.
EXECUTE SAFE THIRD COUNTRY
AGREEMENTS.
DECLARE THE MEXICAN CARTELS
FOREIGN TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS.
HERE'S MY WORRY THOUGH, JESSE.
I WORRY THAT ALL OF THIS IS A
RUIZ.
REUSE.
THE PRESIDENT INTENDS TO
INTRODUCE A BILL IN CONGRESS I
WILL ENFORCE THE LAW AS SOON AS
YOU GRANT PEOPLE HAD ARE IN OUR
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AMNESTY.
I WORRY ESPECIALLY THAT HE WILL
CONVINCE ENOUGH REPUBLICANS TO
TAKE -- THE TO TAKE THE BULLET
TRAIN TO CHURCH TOWN AND VOTE
FOR THE BILL AND IT WILL BECOME
LAW AND THAT WILL MAKE THE HUMAN
TRAIN WRECK AT THE BORDER
IMMEASURABLY WORSE.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WON'T STAND FOR IT NOR SHOULD
THEY WHEN WHEN YOU POLL WHETHER
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS
APPROPRIATE.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT IT
ARE 23-YEAR-OLD GENDER STUDY
MAJORS.
THE REST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SAY IT'S AGAINST THE LAW, DUH,
ENFORCE THE LAW.
>> Jesse: DUH, EN40S